devant merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et à monsieur olivier audibert 3
qui me soit tout d'abord permis de
rendre hommage au lieutenant colonel
patrick vallot tué accidentellement en
mission en guinée ainsi qu aux
militaires blessés en irak et au
nord-mali ces dernières heures
monsieur le premier ministre plus de
soixante et dix mille soldats ont été
déployés sur le territoire national en
2015 au titre de l'opération sentinelle
6 2 tout en nos forces armées sont
intervenues sur le territoire national
jamais elles ne l'ont été de façon aussi
importante et durable faisant peser de
lourdes contraintes sur nos soldats
usure physique et morale enchaînement
opérations extérieures opérations
intérieures entraînant jusqu'à 220 jours
d'absence de leur foyer ralentissement
de la préparation opérationnelle métier
renoncement à certaines formations non
participation à des exercices
internationaux
par ailleurs nos concitoyens découvre
que nos soldats chargés d'assurer leur
sécurité ne sont pas dotés des mêmes
prérogatives que nos forces de sécurité
intérieure palpations de sécurité
fouilles des bagages des véhicules
contrôles d'identité sont toujours
proscrit à nos soldats
après l'engouement suscité par ce
déploiement dès janvier 2015
divers incidents insultes menaces
agressions physiques à l'encontre de nos
soldats n'ont pu nous laisser
indifférent le déroulé de la sombre
soirée du bataclan à rappeler à tous que
nos armées ne peuvent agir avec les
mêmes moyens que police et gendarmerie
et le recours en justice un avocat des
familles des victimes
sonne comme une alerte avant que le
piège ne se referme définitivement sur
nos armées et que ce lien si particulier
entre elles et les français ne soient
durablement écornée comment envisagez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
un retrait progressif de nos forces
armées au profit des forces de sécurité
intérieure
dont le rôle et les moyens semblent plus
adaptés r6 américaine assure yves le
drian ministre de la défense monsieur le
président monsieur mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député audibert
troin d'abord je voudrais m'associer à
l'hommage que vous avez rendu à nos
forces spéciales là où elles sont là où
elles combattent
elles le font avec courage et avec un
grand professionnalisme
sur la question de sentinelle vous avez
vous-même redit à l'instant que la
mission de nos forces armées pour la
protection de nos concitoyens sur le
territoire national n'est pas une
nouveauté il fut un temps ça s'appelait
la défense opérationnelle du territoire
ça fait même partie des missions
essentielles de nos forces armées que de
sécuriser nos concitoyens d'ailleurs le
livre blanc pour la défense de 2008
l'avait déjà anticipé et en 2013 nous
l'avons concrétiser sur la forme d'un
contrat opérationnel qui est aujourd'hui
en raison de la menace mobiliser au plus
haut niveau
dix mille personnel en permanence pour
assurer notre sécurité et pour assurer
les trois missions de protection de
dissuasion et aussi la mission de
réassurance des français en cohérence
avec les forces de sécurité intérieure
est temps que la menace du rat à ce
niveau la sentinelle sera déployé au
même niveau
ça fait partie de notre arsenal de
protection que les français apprécient à
chaque fois que je puis l'occasion de
parler avec nos concitoyens ils trouvent
que la présence des forces armées
rassure alors c'est vrai que au départ
il ya eu quelques difficultés de
personnel d'effectifs de
mobilité de d'hébergement mais les
moyens qui ont été mis par mon ministère
permet de régler cette affaire d'autant
plus que la force opérationnelle
terrestre va être renforcée de 70000 à
77 milles personnel et donc monsieur le
député je voudrais à mon tour rendre
hommage aux forces de sentinelle parce
qu'il faut à ces hommes et ces femmes
beaucoup de sang froid beaucoup de
vigilance et beaucoup d'expérience